(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) A estratégia utilizada por uma parcela das pessoas
que arrematam imóvel em leilão é usar esse
imóvel para gerar renda passiva mensal através da
alocação do imóvel.
Estudos indicam que a média mensal de alocação
de um imóvel rende entre 0,4%
e 0,5% de renda mensal, levando
em consideração o valor do aluguel com o
valor de mercado.
Então, a média de alocação anual ficaria entre
4,8% e 6%, dependendo de por
quanto você conseguir a alocação do seu imóvel
mensalmente.
E aí, qual é a vantagem de usar
um imóvel arrematado em leilão para gerar renda
passiva?
Como você pegou esse imóvel em leilão por
40, 50% do que esse imóvel vale,
e você vai alugar esse imóvel pelo preço
de mercado do imóvel, não vai ter nenhuma
distinção, o seu rendimento anual pode ser muito
potencializado.
É comum que em alguns casos de imóvel
adquirido em leilão, o rendimento possa chegar a
1% ou até mais do que 1
% de rendimento mensal com a alocação daquele
imóvel, porque vai ser o valor médio de
alocação daquele imóvel dividido pelo valor que você
pagou no leilão, e não pelo valor de
mercado.
E como o valor que você pagou no
leilão é inferior ao valor de mercado, esse
rendimento vai ficar potencializado.
Então isso é uma das estratégias que você
pode utilizar alugando o imóvel que você arrematou
em leilão mensalmente.
Você pode ter ali então um rendimento próximo
de 12% ao ano, que é um
rendimento excelente, ainda mais hoje em dia considerando
a baixa taxa de juros que estamos vivenciando.
Saiba que se você fizer essa opção por
alugar o seu imóvel, você já deve afastar
aqueles pensamentos de que alugar um imóvel dá
muito trabalho, que existe grande chance do inquilino
ser inadimplente e te gerar prejuízos.
É possível que você delegue essa função de
alugar e administrar aquele imóvel alocado a alguma
empresa.
Hoje em dia existem inúmeras empresas que realizam
esse serviço.
Existem algumas empresas que te garantem ainda o
pagamento do aluguel, caso o inquilino não faça
aquele pagamento.
Um exemplo de uma empresa que trabalha dessa
forma, que já está atuando em várias cidades
no Brasil, é o Quinto Andar.
O Quinto Andar tem essa garantia de que
se o inquilino não pagar o imóvel, não
importa, você como proprietário vai receber de qualquer
maneira aquele valor, porque eles te garantem aquele
pagamento por um número de meses estipulado e
durante esses meses a própria empresa está agindo
para promover o despejo daquele locatário.
Então esse procedimento fica muito facilitado.
Basta que você contrate uma empresa e aí
obviamente você vai ter uma remuneração mensal para
essa empresa, cada uma aplica uma alíquota sobre
o valor da alocação mensal, mas essa é
uma forma prática de você alugar um imóvel
sem que você tenha nenhuma dor de cabeça.
E aí também existe aquele velho questionamento, vale
a pena alugar fixo ou por temporada?
Dependendo da localização do seu imóvel, pode ser
que ele tenha uma grande rotatividade para alugar
por temporada.
Por exemplo, imóveis localizados próximos aos centros de
grandes cidades sempre atraem bastante gente interessada em
locação por temporada, porque essas grandes cidades atraem
inúmeros trabalhadores que precisam realizar trabalhos específicos ou
reuniões e precisam ficar na cidade por um
curto período de tempo.
Então pode ser que esse seu imóvel seja
bem localizado e que vale a pena você
alugar por temporada.
Também tem exemplos de imóveis que valem a
pena ser alugados por temporada em cidades com
praia ou em cidades com montanha que atraem
visitantes exatamente para desfrutar dessas qualidades da cidade.
Então você deve analisar se no seu caso
específico, se o seu interesse for ter uma
renda passiva mensal, se vale a pena alugar
aquele imóvel de forma tradicional ou por temporada.
E aqui o mesmo pensamento se aplica.
Caso você faça a opção por alugar por
temporada, além das várias opções de sites que
existem hoje exclusivamente com essa finalidade, como o
Airbnb, o Booking, que permitem que você anuncie
seu próprio imóvel atraindo pessoas interessadas em alugar
por um curto período de tempo, você também
pode delegar essa função a algum profissional.
Existem vários profissionais hoje em dia que cobram
porcentagem para administrar aqueles seus imóveis.
Então você não tem que ter nenhum trabalho
quanto a receber a pessoa no seu imóvel,
depois de realizar a limpeza, quando a pessoa
sair para que outra pessoa possa alugar novamente.
Esses profissionais cobram essa porcentagem e realizam todo
esse serviço.
Então tenha em mente que caso seja seu
interesse, você pode realizar essa renda passiva mensal
através da locação de um imóvel que você
arrematou em leilão.
E essa locação vai ser ainda mais vantajosa
porque você vai alocar pelo preço médio de
mercado, mas você pagou um valor bem abaixo
do preço de mercado naquele imóvel, o que
pode gerar um rendimento mensal e anual bem
expressivo.
Fique com essa ideia em sua mente.